hello carriage the radio show here at
the downtown independent after the LA
screening a ride the divine here mr.
hunter weeks director ray by the divine
and Mike Dion executive producer and
also a wire in right the divine and I
wanted to talk to you Mike about first
off when you made the decision to go on
the race did anyone try to talk you out
of it here you already have a family
since when you work a full-time job I'm
assuming you have responsibilities and
here you're going to go on this race and
ride 27 11 12 2711 miles across the
continental divide yeah that's what did
anyone ever try to talk me out of it i
don't no one really tried to talk me out
of it but i was following the race for a
couple years before we actually did the
fillmore before i even wrote it so we
did the did the route and i raised it
and we filmed in 2008 but in 2007 I was
actually considering stepping up and
doing the event but I think the year
before yeah I kind of talked myself out
and out of it my wife kind of you know
wasn't quite sure what you know what it
was all about so so I guess we maybe
talk to each other I'll talk me out of
it at that point but the seed was
planted at that particular point where
it kind of germinated and then a year
later it became a little more
and an acceptable idea very supportive
spouse yes yes wonderful so for you
hunter as far as wanting to direct the
film and put the project together take
us back to where you were in your life
at that time and did anyone try to talk
you out of it didn t want to support you
with it sure yeah it was a interesting
time for me actually when my first got
in touch because I had I was just
wrapping up edit and the kind of final
stages of my second film called ten
yards and this was a film that Josh I
after doing fairly well with my first
film 10 miles per hour pushed out there
really hard really fast we had this
great idea we thought it'd be a huge
instant hit which was a documentary golf
fantasy football this huge just a huge
kind of obsession in the sports
communities but it just turned into this
project that was just so difficult for
us because of a number of different
reasons that where we were at with our
lives and how things are transitioning
and just kind of the way we approached
the film and so it was really tough time
you know and it was like I didn't know
if if I was going to be done with the
film don't make it at that point and I
think that the challenge you have is you
have people in your lives like
girlfriends that kind of get tired of
watching you make nothing and use your
own money and use your credit cards and
you're just struggling along with times
and its really tough so there was there
was a lot of thought on whether or not I
could get involved in this project did
Josh as well
you know Josh decided he would go for
time to work at this time in life just
to make more money and consistent line
so that was really tough but he decided
to help for a week of shooting for the
film and I decided to do the production
and shoot it with Mike and then I would
go on from there and you know we worked
out an arrangement the main sense I hope
some doing more but I didn't know that
would be able to or not and it's you
know I'm really fortunate that we stuck
together and work really hard from the
very beginning at that point I mean he
had been thinking about it working on a
little bit before that but to this point
we're now we've gotten it out as a very
successful film and you know so I'm
really happy i did but there was moments
there for sure what I was that's not
sure I would so write the divine as your
third feature correct so you have 10
miles per hour and then 10 yards I'm
wondering has the success of ride the
divide enhance the views the buzz around
your other two storms yeah it's
definitely definitely helped especially
with 10 miles per hour you know we kind
of we let 10 yards sort of it still
lives out there on its own and you know
there's some itunes downloads and a few
DVD sales here and there but it's pretty
quiet in terms of its success traffic i
guess and that's just it might be our
own self creek tality towards the film
at that time in life and what happened
but we've seen a you know considerable
considerable action with 10 miles per
hour since this film's come out and it's
me it's like it's kids come back to life
again were just talking the sales agent
international sales agent for ride the
divide over the last few days and he's
like now now we're getting all this
interest some tampons
I'm actually getting offers right now on
10 miles per hour so you know it's nice
to see that happen it's good to see that
the youtube views pick up on it
tomorrow's the first feature-length
documentary on youtube and so it's a
nice down so you can get a lift because
we did a big YouTube stunt would ride
the divide and so it just kind of puts
it out there again you know you've been
telling me about some people that want
to want to screen up to you know we've
got a new screening set up at a place
where we screen ride the divide it so
it's kind of neat to see it have this
rebirth and to find that there's tons of
untapped audience still finding out
about there's you know something about
that to think about just the
distribution where are you able to do an
exclusive or non-exclusive deals and it
and you're thinking about that if you
are in it for the long haul if you can
kind of create a non-exclusive sort of
scenario with your library if you can
get three four five films that you still
are able to kind of hold on to a lot of
the if you haven't sold all of the you
know distribution rights of course
you're going to show the distribution
rights if someone's going to offer you
the right amount of money or the right
check but if you can hold onto those
rights well think about seven to ten
years down the road if you've got five
films and you are you know I can in the
library that you haven't really sold off
the writin's that's holds about who
actually for exactly what butter just
said is as you continue on in your
career and you know your fifth film is
an Academy Award winner which is you
know will affect you know everything in
your back library if you still own
so you've had many partnerships one of
which is with LIVESTRONG and you've
raised a great sum of money for them did
you meet Lance Armstrong and tell us
about how this partnership began one
anyway a talk we met Lance yeah we're
going to beat us up you know it's coffee
you've got it you got to take the Lance
back down think you're going to do
anything with my strong you have to
realize what first or more most matters
there and that is you know dealing with
this huge challenge that we have it in
hit our modern-day society which is
cancer you know and the many people that
are that are struggling with that and
the other that there's such an endurance
factor to having to face that you know
if you have to deal with it so I think
there were you know the idea was that we
had something that was very uplifting
and it was an ignorance of it event that
you have to fight really hard through to
get to the finish line you know and not
everybody finishes unfortunately so that
was there was this natural time we felt
was right for the LIVESTRONG foundation
because of that and it helped that there
was cycling you know we're part of the
roots of what Lance arms did you know
and and so forth so that was they just
seemed like the right place did to go
but there's there's a lot of other
reasons too there was an inspiration in
kind of my life as you know getting back
into cycling or Elvin Nelson who's
otherwise known as the fat cyclist he
has a blog called fat cyclist calm and
he was someone when I was still in
corporate America that I would read his
blog and he would tell these fantastic
stories about doing the leadville 100
which is a pretty fantastic undermount
mountain by grayson in Colorado and I
would sit in my cubicle reading is his
stories and just getting sucked in it
and that was actually the inspiration to
get back on a bicycle and start writing
and then enter the leadville 100 and
complete the leadville 100 which you
know because of that you know ride to
divide it was just sort of the next step
from there but his life was effect
his wife was affected by cancer and the
LIVESTRONG foundation really stepped up
to support their family what they were
going through and he really became a
huge advocate of the LIVESTRONG
foundation and how it really supported
their life when he started fundraising
and using cycling and his blog page to
really do that and and since he was such
an inspiration to me I really reached
out with him and partnered with him and
really kind of tying with the lid strong
foundation there was a few other things
and I know you've kind of got your own
reasons as well yeah and it was just
exciting to take a film that has such a
positive message it's so inspirational
and figure out how to take that even
further you know that and that and as we
went through it we learned a lot and
really really grew to have a whole
different sense of the organization and
what they're doing and how good is and
how important it is to try to give back
if you can and so it's been it's been a
cool experience to go through you know
and I think back to our time and
Sundance Slamdance at the beginning of
this year when we just realized in
social and everyone
and that was a point in time when we
decided we were going to make the effort
to work for that organization
how many days were you on the world
filming we shot for probably a total of
twenty-five maybe 27 days I think you
had 28 25 days from you know say from
bamf until matthew finish was about 25
days and then we made our way back to to
Colorado and then once we and then
what's married was kind of getting to
the finish line I flew I flew back to El
Paso and then kind of follow-up Mary in
the last couple days good month so what
was life like once you got back well
it's definitely the event itself I mean
took a lot out of you know might be an
athlete and also the knee and jumping
off a film crew and working hard part
there to get the store and then me
working hard on it I I took off I had to
miss the ending with mary since i had a
film conference in ireland style hatred
great oak was a heavy but we know that
that could that kind of came together
but after that it was like okay what now
you know laughs now I've got this huge
amount of footage just like any
documentary you got it the brush of
shooting it and having that experience
kind of comes crashing down T and I'll
say like oh my god this is going to take
months and maybe longer Mike was really
optimistic that we could pull this all
together for five months I think and I
was like it's gonna project that
optimism we have throughout this whole
thing and annoying blind blind optimism
so it was a lot of work and and it was
kind of this challenge of okay you know
we've gotta we gotta get some commercial
projects happening in focus there you
know because it's time to pay some bills
you know that's I think that's the
constant struggle it with a documentary
film often you know is that you don't
necessarily get all of the funding or
any film and really don't get all
funding and what job you know sometimes
you do there's definitely cases where
that happens and that's what we all
strive for him but a lot of times I
think we're finding ways to
compartmentalize the funding process of
making a film and so you know we had to
be that we had to find find time and
fines
funding to get this thing finished and
so it took it took almost a year I'd say
to really really go through the whole
edit process from start to finish and
get it sure yeah how does life change
you know any time you cut it you know
reach out and say yes to a goal look and
accomplish something it's pretty
rewarding and then even something like
this where you're out the middle of
nowhere in the Rocky Mountains it's it's
get a different perspective of what is
out there instead of big cities in
corporate America you know you see a
whole other world and it's pretty
fantastic so you you start realizing
gosh dude do cities do I need to be in a
city or or or can I have a pretty
wonderful existence in middle of nowhere
Montana are Mexico's